all right
let me just check this
all right it says excellent connection
stream is fully operational uh if there
are any people present in the chat let
me know if everything is working nicely
I haven't streamed in a while as I as I
do stream very rarely
uh but uh yeah I should be should be
working nicely
uh so just let me know yeah I I see some
people in the chat already rainy Rose
Joshua tripathi Emil uh from an audune
uh judgesh uh all right so is the audio
okay is the video okay
is the is the
is is our guests video also fully
operational you can't see me yeah I know
you can see me you have to no it says
excellent connection so everything
should be should be fine
all right yeah there's a 15 second delay
so you should be you should see my
camera now
all right let me just check yeah it's
working we we have both cameras now
all right Gavin says all is okay Kevin
Krueger says smiley faces so should we
should be okay
Ron Menon hello everyone hello to you
sir
I think David is hidden right
you don't want to see me here
yeah he's uh he's a bit yeah maybe a
little bit to the right okay Shady Osama
says both videos about cameras is
working always okay here Chris Hammer
hello from Canada emo box much better
now hello Mr Vladimir pavliv how is
meadow meadow is very well he's chilling
in the back as you can see doing doing
very nicely
ah okay so basically what what today's
about we will be discussing uh what is
the immortal game it's a it's a new
service basically a new online playing
platform for chess that is uh well for
the moment uh still still in in the
works but it is fully operational yeah
although it still says beta on your on
your website so when do you when do you
feel that it will it will get out of
beta
I mean we are still in beta now it's
been it's been better since in July uh
probably at the end of the year if the
tech team is working uh working well if
we all do good works we're gonna leave
the better mode to be to be fully
released uh but yeah for now for now
beta it's uh
it's a better way yeah we kept the beta
and it was Alpha for the for the ogs
that uh tried it a couple of months ago
they know that beta is so much better
than uh the alpha uh was but uh the the
current beta is uh is pretty decent now
and the fluidity and the matchmaking are
pretty great so uh happy with the
current version and uh excited to share
uh what will be shipped in the coming
weeks but will uh go a bit deeper on
this later I assume yeah and okay for
for for just the actual start uh would
you guys please introduce yourselves
before before we actually start
sure sure yeah sure so my name is David
I'm co-founder at Mortal game I'm
leading the tech part so CTO of motor
game
um I was I'm a Dev for like 12 years now
I was pretty involved in crypto in the
past for the past four years mostly in
the D5 Finance uh crypto and yeah since
one year and a half fully fully involved
in the immortal game
and uh hi everyone I'm Joseph Hua and uh
so uh a co-founder of immortal game two
an entrepreneur uh that met David a year
and a half ago with Thomas our third
co-founder and uh we got very excited
about what web3 can bring to uh uh
existing businesses activities Fashion
sports and other subjects and uh chess
was one of the biggest and uh and the
most untouched uh game that we picked
and the learning curve was very low
because uh uh almost a billion people
know how to play chess already so we
thought it would be very relevant to uh
bring the community and put it at the
center and the heard of it and try to uh
to uh to see how we can give back to the
communities the values of a chess
platform through uh gamification
monetization and uh and also a pure ux
and the and Global Experience as a chess
player
and what is your what is your actual
connection to chess why chess
so yeah so Thomas one of the the third
co-founder is a big chess players who
were old since uh I guess since Kobe and
since uh since the queen zombies on
Netflix we all started playing playing
with [ __ ] uh now I'm really addicted
but at this time I was still a beginner
and so we just met uh one year one year
a half ago talking a bit about crypto
what what we can bring and we start
thinking about oh it would be cool to
have some some chess games Unchained and
and the ID came came after a few months
to to have this this new set of tools
where the rule of Chess uh stay the same
uh but you had this gamification on top
of that with the quest we will talk
about it later I guess uh so yeah we all
kind of connected to chess a different
level and and on my side uh when you are
a later adopter because you joined chess
uh so I've played chess uh when I was a
kid and that's cool but uh when you uh
got back to chess and you uh realized
that the um offers that you have online
are pretty much the same then a couple
of years ago uh you you we saw that we
had something to play here uh to bring a
better user experience better content
and better entertainment around it and
web3 could have been the the one of the
one of the paths to to go to there so uh
that's with the the cons yeah the the
the we we noticed that uh it was kind of
the same uh for the past years and
wanted to add something more and uh we
now uh been working on this uh for the
past one year and a half
okay so uh we're gonna get a bit uh
we're gonna go a bit deeper into the
what the Mortal game is and what what
you can do what uh what what future will
bring for the game uh but uh also for
for this stream uh you guys have decided
to throw a little tournament so uh for
everyone who wants to join the
tournament there is a link in the
description of this um of this Stream So
the first thing you will see should
should be a link uh I will just check
one more time if if it's there uh but uh
pretty sure that that everything is
fully operational let me just check yeah
it's uh uh basically the first thing you
will see and there you can click it you
can register for for the website and you
can enter the tournament and uh you guys
uh are welcome to join in there will be
some prizes basically everyone will win
a prize whoever participates in the top
three places will be rewarded um
uh a bit more handsomely uh do you guys
uh do you guys already know what the
rewards for first three places will be
yes so we decided to um to reward the
top three with some Immortal pieces we
will explain a bit later what what they
are but the first one will be a polished
pound uh second one would be a king a
rough King and third one would be uh raw
fruit if I recall correctly and everyone
in the in the tournament will win some
CMT a Checkmate token which is the the
in-game token on Immortal game
all right uh so or is is everyone able
to to to to find the link in the
description
and maybe Antonio just to add something
yeah
um immoral game is a chess platform
before all so it's only it's uh fully
free to play and the gamification mode
and the monetization is accessible uh
without uh paying or having any uh
crypto nft or web3 knowledge uh it's
important to say it so uh there's no
entry barrier for uh people that don't
know how it works it's just a classical
chess game where you can try other game
mode and uh and try to uh discover these
web 3 opportunities uh
with the Ageless PC so we'll talk a bit
a bit later about this but these are the
free to play pieces that give you the
opportunity to play with the exact same
mode than the people that buys nft and
uh but overall uh we have the regular
games that can be played and it's uh
fully free to play yeah okay and for
people asking uh yeah you still can't
see the tournament I've put the link in
the description and also in the chat you
can just click on it and you have to
make an account I believe it takes some
10 seconds to make it it's really not uh
not time consuming and then the
tournament will appear here on the home
page next the next play I believe it
will be anybody friend computer and then
the tournament will pop up
so yeah they can just go on on the play
page and you will see you will see I got
my third tournament on top of it with
the with the setup
uh already done so stand up uh three
minutes I should be live I think in a
few seconds
all right I was I was uh I was uh
weirded out by I was trying to make a
tournament of my own but uh there was no
feature to make a tournament so for the
moment only you guys can make a
tournament yeah not yet yeah not yet but
it's something we have in mind obviously
uh that should come uh
soon this year but for now it's uh it's
it's recognized so if you refresh the
page now
um Antonio if you refresh the main page
you should see
uh it's the it's the I got Metro MMA
tournament so so you can choose the agad
mature tournament uh and then yeah start
to play like this and then you can
directly launch the game by clicking
play okay
so this is what you guys will see and
next the weekly leaderboard there will
be an agat Matra ma that's the
tournament and then you just go click
and hit play it uh it's uh the time
control is three minutes plus zero
seconds increment uh they thought about
making it a five plus so but I thought
maybe it's better for the for the stream
and for the tournament at three plus so
some people would even enjoy bullet but
I thought okay let's let's keep it the
nice clean Blitz
and here I will go to I can go to watch
and then I believe I can uh observe the
games as they are being played yeah so
when you go on uh watch you can take all
the games yeah we're gonna hit standard
Blitz
and uh with the tournament has
officially begun yeah
yeah it's uh it started now so okay so
it's a it's a one one hour tournament
yeah one hour but we decided to take
like the 10th first games yeah I know I
know I know
so yeah yeah so your first 10 games will
be taken in account and uh you can of
course play as much as you want but uh
yeah only two to ten first one will uh
give your points to the leaderboards
yeah and it's sort of a sort of a safety
feature as well as uh it's uh for the
moment it's like in poker a player can
play multiple games at a time yeah yeah
exactly yeah that's something that I I
found that was very very odd why would
why would you why would that be allowed
I mean wouldn't it be better if it would
be one game per account
I mean that that's something we
discussed a lot internally so we we had
at some points the this restriction of
one game their account they're from at
that time
um so we are currently beta testing
testing a b testing Sorry a few few
features so for example now we are open
to more more games by user at a given
moment but it changed uh over the time
so we are currently in a phase where we
are testing uh stuff mostly okay and
also something that I'm also interested
in once someone joins the tournament the
opponents will be uh the opponents will
be matched automatically that you don't
have to do anything
yeah it should be automatic so when when
you click on Play It's just looking for
someone your ELO so uh for the new
players uh they will be matched because
they'll have an average ELO which is uh
undefined and for the existing players
that are in your community uh they will
be ranked with uh and matched with uh
people there you know yeah okay for
those who make the account now they will
pretty much all be the same ELO so they
should be matched pretty pretty quickly
yeah
[Music]
all right so as the tournament is uh is
moving forward uh we can we can discuss
about what the immortal game is so what
is uh what is the core of the immortal
game what is uh uh what what what's uh
what makes it different from chess and
what makes it interesting for a chess
player to to engage in it
so the vision that we have is uh chess
is uh so chess is uh something that you
play uh usually for life and the
community is strong and uh we we wanted
to bring the community back at the
center of it and uh offering the
opportunity to gamify your experience as
a as a player uh owning the PCS uh as a
collection and uh and trading them uh
finding also other game modes so we
haven't talked about it yet but uh what
we uh started as a as a the first game
mode with side quest is exactly the same
game that you know uh same rules and uh
Checkmate is the main objective but you
can purchase or play with free to play
pieces so these pieces represents for
example Bishop a rook a knight and they
will have some additional quests so
today the tournament is just a regular
tournament with a classical chess game
but uh later on if you want to try it
these sort of quests could be like
Global let's say uh winning in less than
40 moves but they can also be ticked to
one piece for example that Bishop uh
should be the first piece of your team
to capture uh or this piece should not
move at all so if you own that piece and
play with it in a game and achieve the
quest then you will get some rewards and
this rewards will go to a certain
leaderboard and every week we reward the
top players from that leaderboard so it
gives you a new way to play chess but
respecting the origin uh rules that we
didn't want to change and uh and so
that's the first gamified option that
we've offered and there is so many uh
interesting reason that we've done it
but uh just check one uh for example
Antonio you're probably better than a
bunch of your community so if you play
with them that's a bold statement
so so if you play with someone let's say
that is better than you let's uh make it
the other way
um if the if the spread is too big uh
one of the players can take difficult
quests to um add some spice to it and
then it will balance the level we've got
the chance to play a lot of games with
uh mvl and other uh top ranked players
and that makes it very fun to balance
the level and uh it also allows some
content creators to create different uh
uh weather play and uh and balance level
so that gameplay is what is the first
one that we've been tested and so far we
have a big stickiness on this because we
noticed that the people like to play uh
that way it's changing a little bit and
uh I think you've uh project yourself
also in the fact that it could help on
the learning tools if we choose some
quests that are linked to openings mid
game or end games then it will also have
these sort of opportunities
so
um yeah that's the the main gameplay
with uh revealed so far and what we want
is uh uh as I said uh use also the
communities to play as teams uh together
and and bring other dimensions and
paradigms than just being white up being
black but playing with the quest and
playing with the the pieces that you own
playing with other people owning the
same sort of pieces for example becoming
uh teams making tournaments with this
sort of theme so that's a lot of
possibilities uh I don't want to be too
long on this but uh the the idea is to
offer a new well played chess respecting
the main rules and will it be like a one
one uh Quest per piece or can piece have
multiple quests
um for now there is one Quest per piece
but okay the the data model is made in a
way that you get we can at some point
add some uh some quests to a piece uh
after for example some leveling up
meaning that you you play with it you
train your piece at some point you can
unlock another Quest that will make
these specific nft specific piece more
attractive or
cooler because it has two quests
attached to it and for example it's
funny because some people just purchase
pieces but because they they think they
are cool and they look nice but uh some
other will focus on the quests uh
attached to it and uh We've noticed that
a lot of people have started to work on
the meter of the game because they are
uh pretty good chess players and the the
they understood how uh how rewarding is
one Quest compared to their ability to
use it so they stop to uh purchase or to
try it a lot and they get some data so
it's also a way to not play chess but to
uh think about Chess and uh just to uh
it's not betting it's not gambling it's
just using your knowledge that you've
learned for many years on chess to uh to
uh stop playing and purchasing uh yeah
Collectibles that you can use uh and
that you can trade sometimes uh for
getting some new ones and there will be
all show some other options
using your different PCS in your
portfolio to make them work together in
different developments so you can see
progressively as a video game uh based
on chess and respecting the the rules
and not just something that is uh yeah
it's I want to insist on the fact that
we respect the rules because we don't
see the point of doing it differently uh
people love to play chess uh variants
but this is not a big variant as you
play with the exact same exactly the
same pieces at the beginning and the
objective is uh is to checkmate
yeah and uh yeah as I understood it you
will for example you can uh own a piece
that has certain quests but you can also
uh borrow it from someone who has it to
play with it yeah is that is that
function already operational
that's correct for now we are testing
these features with deals so basically
guilds are a group group of players that
put some some piece and and delegate
them to some players so if if I want to
play but I I don't I don't know maybe
the the money to get in uh or or I don't
I don't want to put everything I can
just go to a guild and say oh I'm a good
player play with the guild and there's a
fee sharing model so that's definitely
possible to borrow and land pieces but
for now it's uh it's currently being
tested on in the field but at some point
the idea is that anyone can just buy a
piece if you can play because you are in
holidays you can just lend it to someone
um to play with it and at some point it
could be generalized to everyone
and yeah imagine the the amount of
people that quit chess when they were
young because they didn't have the money
to uh uh spend yeah spend time on chess
and have to do something else for a
living and uh with this uh your level
wherever you are in the world uh can
help you to join a guild and play as a
complementary salary or your main one
and uh and we want it to be
um yeah something offered to everybody
and uh and living from your passion is
uh always a tough thing I think Antonio
you're one of the you're one of the
happy few uh probably uh living uh of uh
from chess and uh this is an opportunity
uh to uh to a lot of people to make a
little bit of money out of their time
and their passion
okay and will it be like uh if someone
is the owner of a certain piece with a
certain Quest and someone borrows it uh
for for for play uh is it like uh what's
the what's the distribution of rewards
like is it the 50 50 is it agreed upon
between the two parties what's uh what's
it like
so this is purely business so this is
not us that drive it so if you want to
if you want to own something and uh I
don't know I do a 50 50 fair enough but
uh we are not uh part of it it's just uh
deals that can be made together so uh
yeah uh so you can make any deal
whatever you want yeah we we we can uh
yeah there are like we can give you some
recommendation on the market practice
okay we want to be uh uh yeah hard on
this
okay and there is a there's quite a lot
of talk in the world I don't know if you
guys have heard about it but there's
quite a lot of talk about cheating in
chess so as this is uh something that's
monetized how do you how do you plan to
deal with that I mean do you win a game
and then you immediately are rewarded or
does it go through some sort of a
filtering process or something
yeah definitely so just as uh all the
other platforms with uh uh invested a
lot of time and energy and teach it so
we ban a thousands of players every day
and uh we can say it uh like yeah it's a
reality and uh we also believe that uh
the community will play a big role in it
and uh when you see the chess drama and
when you see uh the impact that it has
on previous results and current results
it's uh it's yeah it's very bad and I
think uh the community is so
disappointed of maybe have been having
played against potential teachers uh
that can be random players on the
platform not has to be like celebrities
or uh very uh good players uh whatever
the level so imagine if tomorrow we have
a couple of our uh top players that
um just uh audit the games and uh and
then banned the the players and then the
the nft that they own for example could
be frozen so you have a real risk uh you
spend some money you you take the risk
of uh your repetition but also the money
you invested in it so it make it it
start to become a new barrier uh for
cheating and also what's a big
difference with the game mode with uh
experience there is uh you can use
stockfish with the with uh on your next
step but uh with the side quest uh
you'll probably win all the games but uh
you won't necessarily uh be able to
realize all the quests so at least for
now because I'm sure some people will
develop it sometimes uh uh as soon as we
become bigger but we we this is also a a
a a way to Edge ourselves against
cheating uh with the money
okay and uh one thing that also for
example you win a prize today you will
not get it today you will the you will
get it on a weekly basis or on a monthly
basis or on a
yeah uh exactly what we do is uh when uh
we always delay the reward because we uh
we check out all the games and all the
players uh so we uh the leaderboard that
is every week uh congrats if you're the
first position but uh there might be uh
uh if you're a cheater then you'll lose
your position and get banned and then um
uh there will be another one joining
that first position so yeah we always
delay the the the the the the money and
the pieces that we offer from a couple
of days weeks uh or months depending on
the tournaments
okay and uh What uh uh what what kind of
quests are there uh who makes them and
how many of them are there exactly
I think today we have something like a
little bit less than 50 and uh and most
of them are live and uh so we have a
couple of hundred thousand games that
have been played with them so we have
some that um they're uh difficulty and
uh and yield and uh who made them uh
some of them are pretty uh easy the for
example when you you you have to win
without for uh within 40 moves but uh
there are more complicated ones that
have been ranked so it's either the the
the product team uh composed mainly by
chess players uh here or also one of our
50 chess ambassadors uh that are from
the yeah top 10 in the world players to
streamers and uh all the people that
joined the adventure very early because
they they wanted to also to go to help
us create uh the new way of playing
chess online uh so all of these people
submitted a lot of ideas and we kept the
the the best ideas
okay and
regarding uh regarding the where do you
guys see like this uh this can go like
in maybe a year in five years and do you
see do you have any sort of a big road
map for for the project because it's
already when was The Immortal game
started
like uh the ID started one year and a
half ago uh then we started building it
like uh a bit less than a year ago so
for now obviously as you see we are we
are still in beta mode there's a lot of
progress to be made on the on the
latency and the on the 3D responsiveness
of the website obviously so this is uh
one of the next release that will happen
by October that will uh that will put
model game uh in the same standards as
the competitors because obviously people
are used to uh to the websites uh like
leeches which is chaston that's a very
very solid technical background and
three years experience obviously this is
the song that I want to reach uh we are
getting closer in in a few months that's
that's the idea so first of all I think
having a clean chat product that people
can can join and enjoy the same way they
play another platform and at some point
maybe try to imagine other way of of um
of of gaming uh maybe new game mode to
to be added so that's yeah and one big
thing we want to play uh uh we want to
play also a big role is uh the the way
you learn chess so it's not available
yet on the platform but we think that
gamification is a great key to uh to uh
get the people learn in the right
direction and uh and linking it uh from
the play zone to the learn Zone in the
same platform or the same application is
one of the uh big uh thing that has been
uh uh yeah the focus of the product team
so we we see ourselves as uh the main
chess platform globally uh in the com in
the coming years when you talk about
timing uh five years could be uh uh the
division but also uh the the yeah we see
us as the best way to learn chess online
in the in the close future
sort of uh what as I've heard you will
have sort of uh some uh something called
maybe Interactive Learning where you
will be able to if you're interested in
a subject learned with other people
simultaneously
yeah exactly so we we want to use the
the the the people that trusted that's
already uh from the trend Masters to uh
chat teachers and also uh uh content
creators but also just uh very easily uh
the the fact that when you play a game
if you do uh that sort of mistake twice
we want to push the the real Great
content linked to this and we want to uh
to gamify this uh operation these
operations so uh you you get
incentivized to uh uh keep learning that
opening keep learning that mistake uh
differently than just doing puzzle or
puzzle rushes and uh and I think it's
still missing today and some are doing
pretty good job but uh either they are
good but they are independent in terms
of platform or application and we want
to host everything there so that uh
there's a real link between the the time
you spend learning and the time you
spend playing
okay and also one thing that I I'm
interested in there do you feel like uh
uh as you will be able to to sell these
pieces on the marketplace of the sword
you will you will probably have your own
Marketplace yeah or is it already
operational
yep we have the marketplace on the
website so you can see all the pieces uh
primary market and secondary Market
um
again
this is uh this is not the focus for now
even if it adds the it adds the the
it adds something cool to the project
but the idea is you can play with even
with ageless pieces uh there is no entry
buyer for the players but yeah the
marketplace is already like
and uh do you feel that uh peace will be
worth more if it's uh sort of has some
sort of a status of a rare piece or
something or if it just has a really
really uh easy to perform Quest because
some quests are probably much much
easier to perform than others
yeah that's going to be the the funny
part about it so as it's a nft the cool
part about it it's it's immutable so
once it's minted and chain you cannot
change it uh it's you you own it we
cannot take it back and you cannot Nerf
it as for example if you play League of
Legend at some point some some there is
some nerve happening we cannot do this
so obviously if one piece of a quiz that
it's too easy to fulfill and and can can
bring a lot of points uh Market will
adapt and maybe it can become more
expensive uh at some points uh yeah so
that's the funny part about having it on
chains
we cannot change the way they work
and how how long did it take you to to
actually uh make the make the entire
project operational that people can
actually use it to you know make make an
account log in with a wallet uh uh and
enter the marketplace it was all done
within this year and a half
yep yep so we have we have a few
favorites just leader the first one was
the alpha phase where we had a few few
testers around and we improved the the
project the projects uh month after
months so now we are still in beta uh
there's a huge update uh happening at
the end of October that will hire the
the the standards we have uh but yeah
the whole project took uh one year to to
be built
um the the to be fully operational
yep
all right uh do you guys uh would you
guys appreciate some uh questions from
the audience yeah yeah go ahead please
and is there okay maybe I haven't asked
something that you guys wanted to
discuss is there anything important you
guys maybe wanted to add
no no but um uh you know it's always
interesting when you when you work on a
project and you want to uh you wanna
create a game
um either you can just create it in on
your side and deliver it when it's done
and fully uh fully perfect we decided to
uh build it with the community so that's
why we launched in an alpha and Now Beta
mode so we are very uh aware of uh uh
what we still have to uh to achieve and
the vision has been the same for the
past year and will be the same for the
two coming years uh we are pretty proud
to what has been achieved so far uh
people are matchmaking uh pretty quickly
now a lot of different levels uh the the
the traction either from the player base
to the nft sales is pretty good and uh
and the project is very nice in terms of
ux so we we still have a lot to do and
we we always like to have even help up
comments and how the remarks because it
helps the team also to prioritize what
we want to do and uh so feel free to uh
to to to give us all your thoughts
remarks and what you want us to to to to
do first because if we are building it
it's not for us uh we we can play chess
together already we're building it for
you and for the chess lovers so uh give
us your priorities what you're missing
today and uh we'll be happy to put it on
the roadmap too
where can someone add like a suggestion
for you guys to implement
so we are using this code uh for that
matters so you can join easily uh our
Discord and we have suggest uh
suggestion topic and uh and we follow it
very well and the most trending topic
are added to the roadmap so uh don't
hesitate to uh to go there and uh and uh
into our new ideas too
okay and why do you think there's a
there's this uh sort of um uh when
people in in any area where when people
start the uh gamifying uh sort of let's
say just in this example why is uh why
is the the most people the just the the
sound of something being an nft uh just
doesn't agree with them do you have any
insight in this
you you mean the people that uh don't
really like or free about nfts yeah
yeah so we we know that uh uh nft uh is
a buzzword that is not very uh popular
today and uh and and we understand why
because there were a lot of scammy
projects that uh were uh Quick Cash grab
and that built in uh bull market so
today it's a bear Market where uh it's
not trendy anymore it's in it's or it's
even more challenging but we know what
uh nfts can bring uh as a gaming
gamified options so we we are uh con
yeah we're convinced that they will play
a role uh in in that whole uh platform
and uh and we know that a lot of people
will it will take some time for them to
understand uh what it what it is for and
and what we where we can go with it and
uh that's why we are a free-to-play
platform so everybody can enjoy playing
chess like traditional early and play
with the free to play PCS to just try it
and understand it and then if the people
want to purchase nfts and play with it
and get some money out of it or just
resell it or keep it as Collectibles we
want to be uh yeah it's open to any kind
of thought about this
what is as I I see some people in the
chat uh or also asking uh what is uh
your best definition of an nft as I'm
sure most people still don't uh really
haven't gotten into that
yeah to be honest I'm pretty sure at
some point we will look back at let's
say in 10 years uh uh and so imagine
while you were playing wall okay if
you're playing for example wall of rock
craft then you you had an asset there
but at some point these are saying oh
it's not worth it anymore because we we
make a release because we touch this
currently it's it's it's it's
understandable people will not complain
at some points in 10 years we'll realize
that asset ownership is the is the best
thing you can ask so this is my my asset
my ft I live on chain no one who will
ever be able to to to take it back from
you that's the power of it I think
ownership of assets and that that's that
in my opinion should be the the main
role of the nft uh what you do with it
for example adding it as the assets uh
for playing is different but uh but that
that's that's the the best you can have
uh something you own and you're sure to
own forever and I know there's this is a
very like um
though I'd say in English kivo I don't
know the word but something people
people uh like or really hate and I can
see reading the chats uh NXT is usually
associated with with scam because there
will have a lot of scammy project with
it uh our one of our goals will be to to
to
maybe make people change the way they
think about it uh that's gonna be a hard
Mission because uh I understand
seeing what you see from from the
outside that it's something that it's
coming but that's in my opinion
something really interesting for the
future of gaming and ownership of assets
okay but uh now nfts aside uh regarding
uh just chess your your goal is to also
become like a really really big chess
playing platform like maybe even one to
rival leeches and in chess.com
yeah it's just 24 not to leave anyone
behind but uh okay
yeah yeah that's the vision and uh uh we
we're not just building it for a couple
of nft lovers that the chess we're
building it for uh chess players uh
online and uh we think that this new
layer uh will bring a lot of
opportunities in the future and uh
that's just uh a very thin uh part of
what we want to build and uh and today
the Mark we're a bit early on the market
uh from the video games and and uh games
players because nft there's some uh yeah
some some people that don't believe uh
understand uh what they are and what
they are for but as that David say uh
earlier today when you purchase your
membership on another platform you own
it for a year uh either you play it or
you play on it or not and at the end of
the year it's done it's not yours
anymore you have to pay again uh how we
say it is more
um you pay for what you want to use and
you own it uh either we exist or we
don't exist anymore of course the vision
is that we are here for the long term
but the pieces that you purchase today
uh they are yours and they are uh
they'll be probably uh usable in other
uh Platforms in the future too so we the
community owns uh their asset and they
will keep it and they will never be uh
they will never be ours
when do you when do you feel like uh you
will have a sort of a next update
regarding the the interface itself
regarding uh tournaments regarding
players being able to create tournaments
themselves uh maybe adding a chat uh
while playing someone is that something
that that's happening
so yeah there's a big update that David
can maybe go deeper on but uh on the uh
playing server to make it more scalable
uh to welcome more people and uh that
will be the the main release uh in the
coming weeks and uh once this is done
and stable uh expect it to be current uh
like mid-november uh then we'll we will
be shipping all the features that are uh
developed already but waiting for this
new uh server uh to be deployed so uh
let's say in a month uh we'll be ready
to uh to announce uh a lot more uh
features that we can real that we can
release
okay and I've I've seen your your
promotional video and I think you uh
even tweeted about it and mentioned it
on your website that you you have uh
like 50 50 streamers or promoters
currently you are working with and they
are the they've also created some
tournaments I imagine that uh their
viewers are playing in was there any
sort of feedback were you able to get
some sort of feedback from them
so most of the amount Grand Masters that
you all know uh and uh so these Grand
Masters have been helping us on the game
design and the development of the
platform uh there will also be uh
showcased on the platform during uh
events and tournaments that they can
host and on doors so you can play
against uh these uh amazing uh players
that you have followed in the like uh
yeah top level tournaments and uh so uh
you'll have all the lists on the website
and on the videos and in the Press but
we are very proud to uh have them uh
yeah at their trust since the beginning
and uh when you have the best players in
the world that believe in what you're
building and your vision uh it and one
and one thing to uh to uh to build it
with you it's a strong yeah proof of uh
that the direction is good and uh and
and yeah uh we we want to uh to uh to
use their uh vision and their knowledge
about the chess ecosystem to help us
build uh the Best in Class chess.com for
the future
is the is the actual list of the grand
Masters involved uh public
yeah on this code you you can find it
too could you could you disclose some of
the some of the names that that are
working with you
yeah definitely uh so mvl uh was one of
the first ones uh and uh uh
we we uh you want all the names so no
some of them not some of them them yeah
we did joined us a couple of months ago
Dina two we have Prague uh we have uh
Alexander uh botnik we have uh uh Aryan
Ari we have also streamers like Alicia
santoramo uh so yeah we I can go ahead
to the 50 of them but uh it is arika so
yeah you you can find them probably on
the website but uh you'll have the
existivity of it uh on the Discord
and what uh the the actual interface
like what we are seeing now where the
pieces are moving that is uh how how is
that uh created is is it a copy of
something is it a mimic was it created
from uh from scratch uh in case people
uh I've seen some people in the chat
saying like uh primoves are acting
pretty funny or who who was involved in
that I imagine also also the grand
Masters that are in the project
yeah so so that on technical size
everything is made is made in-house so
obviously it's not perfect yet because
as I mentioned we we are still in beta
and the team is growing but still a lot
of room to progress but everything was
made uh in-house yes
and how uh how many players uh could uh
your current service how many players
can can you accommodate at one point
uh I mean in in parallel right yeah yeah
the playing at the same time
so uh until now we are like
um I mean I think I think the top was
like 200 games at the same time so we
will uh we met some tests uh to what to
have more obviously depending on the on
the condition the seat can can be a bit
a bit laggy at some point depending on
the device so we are working hard to
improve that uh this is what Joffa
mentioned with the next releasing in
October we had very good result from
from what we are seeing in the in the
testing environment so hopefully it will
fix some of the some of the best some of
you guys uh uh talked about on the chat
uh so yeah on October should should fix
yeah that is to be able to host uh
hundreds of thousands of people playing
uh if we want to reach uh the same level
as Leaders or chess comp that you
mentioned
uh all right uh and let me just load
another game
and where where like uh uh at the pace
you you are progressing now uh What uh
what kind of where where do you see like
uh a hundred thousand people playing at
what at what what point do you think it
possible
I think it will be by the end of next
year so uh you know it's uh it's it's
like a snowball as a PVP game uh as as
much as you have player as much as you
retain them because they find the right
opponent and today we've opened only uh
the blitz mode uh in five minutes and uh
as soon as we'll have a bit more players
on the platform we'll often other uh
yeah time options and uh depending on
the time zone uh we expect to have
before the end of the year uh all the
time uh the time mode and uh all the ELO
and uh and all the time zone covered by
instant matchmaking so if we reach that
by the end of the year then uh the bond
rate of the players coming on the
platform will be very low uh because
they'll have the opportunity to play uh
like casual games but also the different
uh
um new games that we are offering them
and I've also I've seen on your on your
promotional video and uh also on on your
Twitter website that you were able to
sort of crowdfund uh I don't know if it
was crowdfunding or some sort of a
private sale that you were able to
gather what like something like 15
million dollars for the project
was that yeah before or after having a
working Pro product
yeah so uh we we got uh yeah some VC uh
joined the the adventure a couple of uh
months ago and it was announced uh later
in September so yeah they we have now uh
15.5 millions of capital that came in
the company to uh to build it to build
the team to build the product so uh we
are still at the very beginning of it in
terms of Team products and all of it but
the vision is to be long term and that
money will help us to uh develop the
best product possible and to offer this
to uh the the biggest com uh the biggest
communities and what's the what's the
size of the of the team actually
creating this this project
we are 20 people uh alphabet is a tech
team led by David and uh we have also
all the designs done internally and then
uh it's mainly uh uh yeah business
Partnerships and uh marketing
and also one thing that I was interested
in uh you you currently have a set of a
set of pieces that that people can
purchase for uh for for playing uh how
often do you plan on uh introducing new
ones into the into the environment
uh yeah so there is there is so there's
this first collection composed of four
elements so we have ebony marble uh
steel and ivory so as as soon as as the
supply because it's a limited supply for
this one uh will be sell uh we we are
still we are already working on on new
new connection uh new design and uh yeah
so depending on on
so it's not sort of like a monthly thing
or or like every three months or six
months it's uh
so what we've done is uh We've uh told
the community how many pieces that will
issue and that's a maximum Supply so
unless uh all the supply is sold out we
won't have a new Supply to uh yeah to
keep the value of it uh how the people
uh saw it when they invested in it and
uh but we we think that that Supply
should be sold out by the end of the
first quarter of 2023 that will and we
have a lot of collaborations uh uh that
that has that will be revealed uh for
the new Collections and uh yeah but
expect this for the the yeah second
quarter of 2023.
and you you mentioned that there are
currently uh you have 50 50 operational
quests that are that are in in
circulation but how many uh how many
pieces actually shared those quests but
so so the distribution of uh this Quest
is uh uh out of the total Supply so uh
yeah all all the PCS can have all the
quests uh pretty much
uh so quests quests are not unique yeah
no no no the quests are not unique and
also uh uh the the communities here also
to propose some more quests and uh we'll
Implement uh the best ones and we are
trying uh with beta testers some more
quests to have data uh to uh to to know
how uh we want to uh to rank them and
how we want to uh uh put the rewards on
them
and we'll uh future future uh I don't
know how to put a future generation of
sets like uh Second Edition or third or
fourth edition will they share quests
with the first edition or or or then
will will new quests come out
um we we to be honest we don't know yet
because that's uh not a big issue for us
that can either uh keep their uh keep
the existing one or get new ones but uh
we know that some of the players for
example Maxim uh MBL uh had some ideas
of quests that he wanted to to put uh on
the platform so he might sometimes uh
communicate on uh chess pieces uh that
as that are that are packed with the uh
his uh Quest ideas
all right so uh uh again uh as uh I've
already mentioned I I might not have
touched on all the subjects is there
anything that you would like to sort of
add that that would be important for the
project and for people who are only
learning about the The Immortal game to
know
so uh I would ask the question in the
maybe opposite way because I've I
haven't followed much the the chat I've
seen only a few comments but uh uh we
are here to build uh what doesn't exist
yet uh what we've been uh building so
far is what already exists but we want
to build it in a better way so anything
that uh you and your community want to
have because it doesn't exist or it's
not good enough
um we'll be very happy to have it uh to
have your sword on it and uh and that
will be also added on the on the roadmap
okay also okay someone is asking in the
comments uh where is the actual money
that you earn while playing coming from
so
um today we are in growth mode so uh 100
of the revenues of the platform are
given back to the community uh we're not
here to make money but we had building a
product and a community so uh uh people
are purchasing uh pieces and uh we don't
get this money for the company we are in
uh yeah uh we're building a product and
the community so
um the main money that we give as reward
is out of this and if we uh if the
people don't buy which is a possibility
because that's not our priority today uh
we'll use the money that the investors
gave us to uh to offer uh decent reward
to the players
and also I I might have uh seen
something in in the in the chat about
the app but uh obviously we'll have a a
a a a a mobile app uh in the coming
weeks so we expect it to be uh ready by
the end of November so this will also be
uh a big uh yeah a big Improvement on
our side as most uh like more than 55
people 55 percent of the people are
playing uh uh on their mobile today
ah they were playing on mobile but via
the via the website
yeah exactly because we yeah it's
playable on your mobile and uh and yeah
majority of the of the players are
playing uh on mobile
all right uh now uh anyone in the chat
do you have uh do you have any questions
regarding the project that you would
like to have answered personally now is
uh now is a very good opportunity as you
have these fine gentlemen here that are
ready to answer your every question
thank you
uh gentleman named Art Hill is asking
currently only guilds can delegate
pieces do you plan to make it available
for regular players to delegate pieces
yep
absolutely for now as I mentioned that
before so for now we are testing the the
idea of Delegation with the guild uh and
uh and improving the the mechanism to be
able to delegate to make it uh open to
anyone but it has to be done carefully
because we we don't want it to we don't
want it to become a nightmare for for
ending and renting because uh it has to
be done on chain on a good way so we are
taking the time needed for for doing it
the right way uh and also since uh a lot
of new people joined and we only
discussed this briefly uh at the
beginning of the stream uh uh people
would like to know uh if you don't mind
uh getting into it once again just how
how do you plan to deal with uh someone
actually cheating on the website as
that's pretty much the main thing
everyone is talking about yeah sure so
obviously this is one of the most
important topic for us and for for
everyone involved in chess because uh
there is a lot of cheaters uh obviously
in in chess and in any game with
interest in particular on online could
be a lot of cheaters especially when
there is a financial incentives as we
are we are proposing so
um so we have like algorithm mechanism
uh as every every main platform and the
idea is is to to build in a way that you
take into account the the quest at some
point and to improve it so we are
recruiting uh a lot in that in that in
that sense build a team how to do that
we also had some people helping from the
Discord
from the from the partnership we have to
determine which can be cheater when the
when the the algorithm is not clear
enough so that's obviously one of the
most important topics and uh it will
always have cheaters the the good
decision is to try to mitigate it as as
much as possible uh to make a platform
enjoyable for everyone
and I I imagine uh you you've mentioned
this at some point someone is asking in
the chat uh why would other platforms
add support for your nfts is that
something you also have uh planned at
some point that you can use nfts from
Immortal game to play on other websites
so it's not planned today uh of course
yeah as we have the the
as we have the Play Zone uh we we think
that uh that's not a big opportunity to
offer to the players to play with these
on other platforms uh so uh yeah that's
not planned today
yeah and also uh something you mentioned
that for the moment uh you are still
discussing whether or not to allow
multiple games uh what's the what's the
what's the pro pro and cons there like
um I imagine okay you should allow
multiple games if someone is holding a
simultaneous exhibition I don't know if
that's also something you guys have
planned that it will be possible to hold
a simultaneous exhibition if someone
wants to let's say if mvl wants to allow
20 players to play against them which
would be
which which would be pretty weird if he
would have to be focusing on 20 quests
simultaneously uh but yeah is that
something that you were also having in
mind
so yeah multiple uh game uh there's a
risk of uh using Bots and uh so we don't
want to have too many games played but
we know also that people want to
challenge themselves in chess and uh and
so uh playing multiple games uh at the
same time is an option we wanted to try
and see how the people uh react and
wanted to uh experience that so uh today
it's working technically uh we're not
sure that we want to keep it and you
know when you're at the beginning of
project like us uh you have to test a
lot of thing and get data on it to know
what will be the direction so uh yeah uh
today it's available
um we it can be changed in the coming
weeks uh it's moving very fast on this
and also I don't know if you have
insight into this as someone also asking
the comments it's a uh how does the ELO
distribution system work is it the same
as as everywhere else or
so so we're using the glyco2 algorithm
uh two so it's the same use uh on
leeches for example so basically we will
get the same the same uh same the hello
more close to legit than you can have on
just come so it's applicable to
algorithm
you meant
I mean on the platform yeah yeah uh is
Elo Distribution on the platform
question uh so for now uh we have a lot
of good players with really high high
ranking uh for now the the beginners we
are we don't have a lot of uh uh
beginners uh that's quite quite funny to
see uh and of course the more player
joining the platform the the more the
more the yellow distributed but uh yeah
it's it's not to be enough at least to
do to do like more and more precise
matchmaking
okay a colleague of mine the neighbor is
asking
um uh what blockchain is the Mortal game
built on and why did you choose this one
so we are built on ethereum but using
using a solution called immutabatics uh
basically imitabelics is a solution
built on top of stockware and Stockwell
is uh is a zero knowledge proof uh
system for for those we know it's very
interesting but we are built on on
metabolics which is on ethereum to
summarize and so so I might have missed
it with all with all the technical talk
but why choose that one uh because
obviously in your opinion ethereum is
the is the
the Muslim shame that the one the one
that will that will pass the years
that's my opinion but for now there is a
uh some problem of scalability and
ethereum obviously the eye eye gas price
gas price the number of transactions per
second you can you can do ethereum so
some people build
um uh some some Layer Two so what you
call Layer Two which is uh let's say a
solution that works with ethereum but
can increase the number of conduction
per second and lower the the gas fees uh
yeah so that's that's uh you keep the
same quality as ethereum but with a
higher higher transaction in per second
than uh and lower gas fees
all right there's a person named Jeff
saying if you guys need a front-end
developer that he's a a killer developer
from Canada let's go man of course we we
have on the website you can go on the
top you have like your carriers open so
you can you can apply and we are we are
seeing everyone uh on this reading every
every uh curriculum video that is sent
so it would be a pleasure if you want to
help help build it yeah I've seen it
it's it's the only one that has like a
green icon and next to it so it feels
very inviting
okay let me just uh scroll through the
chat a bit more
uh Vladimir says I cannot move my Bishop
Okay so
okay a fair question uh why to choose to
play on your website says
so I I think for for now the concert
would be if you like the concept of
quest you want to play something
different you can go Immortal game
um if I have to be free transparent for
now the the text the tech we add is is
not at the level of the one that here
for for the last 10 years and that time
to build it so I would not say if you
would come here for the performance for
now because the plan is to to work on
that but I would say if you want to play
something different try try new new way
of uh of playing with this Quest system
uh if you if you like the concept of
having these nfts and building
strategies on top of that you should
come and have a try on your game
how much did it take you to actually uh
to make quests uh uh viable like uh how
many have you tried before you before
you settled on on these that are
currently in use
oh so so we had like a topic we had like
about 70 quests and at some point we
removed some because they were too hard
or too easy to fulfill and then we had I
think three or four iteration of uh
trying to find the good but the good
points for a request to find the
difficulty of quest and now I think we
have something that is pretty good even
if some quests are better than others uh
yeah now it's Unchained so we cannot
change anymore that's the beauty of it
actually
and uh have you tried uh successfully
fulfilling uh some of the quests
you mean ourselves
uh oh yeah
yeah of course so we're playing uh a lot
and uh and uh I have to admit that uh I
haven't completed all of the quests but
uh if if I can get a tip to uh your
community is uh if you want to try
difficult Quest go and play against the
computer and pick a a bot which has a
low ELO that's the way I try the hardest
quest because if I play against uh like
my uh yeah my level players uh yeah a
lot of the quests are too difficult so
yeah if you want to try difficult ones
go that way
yeah I don't know if we already touched
on this subject uh pip rap asks why do
you think chess needs a gamification
I think gamification is a way to change
also your habits because uh so I think
the majority of the players uh play
because they want to improve their level
uh playing differently uh gives you new
uh paradigms and a new way to think and
change a little bit your like routine of
playing so we think that bringing some
uh different sort of gamification makes
it a more uh fun and more interesting so
uh it has been proven in a lot of
industries that uh and yeah you you yeah
getting gamification uh
is a way yeah to uh to allow you to to
stick more and to stay longer because it
brings it brings new uh New
Opportunities New Reflections
here's a here's a fun question from
Astro short are there limited number of
nft chess pieces created from your
platform and also should a piece have
more value if it was played by a famous
chess player
that's funny uh because it's unseen you
will be able to see who owned uh which
PC so we will be able to track
everything so obviously if it's your
favorite players at a piece and for you
it's it's nice to have maybe it can have
more value for you maybe not for someone
else and regarding the the amount of
Peace uh yes so the supply is is uh is
limited of course so each family have
different scarcity from Ralph To
Masterpiece uh and there is a certain
distribution for every every piece so
it's one one thousand one hundred ten
ten one yeah and this and you have six
pounds
the same
the same distribution you have so you
have um yeah you you will be able to
follow on the blockchain all of the
owners or all of the previous owners of
the piece but will you be able to see
all of the games that for example a
certain Rook was involved in
uh to then no it's not available what
you what you can do is go to a profile
if you play for example if randomly you
you find Antonio playing uh then you can
check his game and uh and check what is
done but uh today we uh we have the API
ready uh and some people ask us to get
some data out of uh for example that
route with that Quest how did it go uh
from what uh ELO and all of this data so
we are just thinking uh today uh how to
use it and what for that we have the
data already just thinking about uh how
to uh give it uh like open and uh
because people must want to use it to
know how to uh like what piece to
purchase what quests and uh where to
invest
okay so you said that for the moment
everything is being uh divided between
the players for the moment you're not uh
focused on profit you're just on
building a fine product uh yomanisha is
asking how do you plan on on achieving
profit after this at some point when you
are satisfied with the product
so there we are uh we are in the growth
mode and uh uh I'm uh the objective is
to either build a product and build a
community and once we'll have a rolling
platform with players uh just purchasing
PCS uh with uh and and just uh getting
involved in the tournaments then uh we
won't have to invest much in marketing
and acquisition so all the costs will go
down and uh and uh as a snowball the the
community and the player base should go
up because uh of his notoriety if your
model game becomes uh then a brand and
uh so chess.com is a Big Brand uh a lot
thanks to his domain names uh of course
but the others like leeches uh got very
well because they've done a trade job on
the on the product and the playability
so we are following the same strategy
but trying to go faster thanks to uh the
trust and and the money of the investors
that backed us very early and thanks to
the advices from the GMS that joined us
too
and also a few sharora is asking do you
need to link your wallet or do or will
the website create one for you
so so if you if you don't have any any
wallet any metamask and you don't know
how it works you can just log in log in
via Google or email password it will be
created under the hood for you and at
some point if you feel ready and then
and then you you want to link your own
metamask your own account you will be
able to do it and and every and
everything will be transferred from the
website to your own wallet
correct uh so both is possible okay
all right let me just uh
browse through the questions a bit more
and you Antonio uh have you tried
already have you achieved any Quest or
for now you've just tried the the
regular version no I've played the I've
played the the regular version to to get
my rating up to 2000 and it was uh it
was fairly fairly easy I don't think
I've lost the game
uh so more uh I believe more stronger
players will be will appear in the
future uh but I did I think I did
struggle you know in a few games so it's
not like uh you know there are there are
absolute beginners I don't know if I've
actually reached 2000 uh I I I I did try
to get it uh but no I haven't tried any
any of the quests yet
okay I know you just just go on the uh
uh ageless spot which is the free to
play and claim the free one and uh and
you'll get the first piece and you if
you achieve the quest then you'll get
the second one so you can start to uh to
uh train yourself with an imposed uh
Quest so uh and challenge yourself
because they are given to you randomly
is that something everyone gets
when they when they join is that uh a
possibility for everyone
yeah every everybody gets it so just go
on the home page and uh on the uh claim
your ageless PCS uh Bots which are the
the free to play pieces that looks like
nfts uh have the same attributes in
terms of game play but uh it's just a
free to play uh pieces the first one
will be a bone with a random Quest if
you achieve the quest then you'll get
the second piece and then uh to complete
your full set so that's also a way to
challenge yourself and to stop and to
try this game game mode
okay Mr MP or is asking besides
gamification how will you help chess
players improve will there be a unique
way of doing it
yeah so
um getting our Academy live is uh is
quite a uh quite a lot of work to to do
but uh we have a team dedicated to this
uh start who started to work on and uh
to be honest uh we we are very ambitious
about what we want to offer to the
communities in terms of learning
experience so it won't be out uh before
a couple of months because uh this if we
want to uh to to be the reference in
terms of uh learning chess we'll have to
uh to build a lot and to try a lot of
things and think out of the box and just
not copy what exists but uh use the
gamification and uh and the the nfts if
we find a way it's interesting but yeah
that's the one of the the main priority
will be to uh to be the the reference as
the learning opportunity and the
learning platform for chess okay so now
uh people got a general idea of what the
immortal game is they've had a chance to
try it out when uh you've mentioned the
sort of a a bigger update coming up when
when is that to be expected
by the end of October the start of
November there's no like a precise dates
but who will announce obviously the the
the community will when it's live
um but it it changed it changed a lot
the the Trinity of the platform is there
somewhere where you can like since you
already mentioned League of Legends when
there's a new patch in League of Legends
you receive everything that was patched
in the patch will people have access to
something like this uh you know what was
added what's new
yeah yep so we have a challenge on the
website so to be honest we didn't update
it uh a lot because it was uh mostly
small updates over the time but at each
big release big updates we will we will
uh at the post on it to explain what
what changed and which version and we
will do it in a more regular way now
starting from now
okay and I believe uh I believe the
tournament has finished but I uh as this
is the first tournament I'm I've held I
don't know how to see the winners is
that something you could help with you
couldn't go on unbelievable so if you
click on the on the top all right
yeah there is a tab called Lego mode
yeah ah there's another matter
tournament leaderboard all right
and so you you can find in the
tournaments you should find yeah
so who's the winner
I believe uh rank one is uh is that if
that's the number of players 209 uh
ended seven minutes ago number of games
556 uh
show dabola is the winner uh now I just
have to see okay so he won he won eight
games drew two games and lost zero games
same as second place shakhmat also eight
to zero and Igor Kowalski with nine wins
zero uh draws and one loss
okay so this is this is very strange
to me at least because uh both of them
have the same amount of points all all
three of them have nine points oh no uh
yeah and uh why is the
ah so draws are valued more than actual
losses because it's the same amount of
points but Igor Kowalski had the most
wins uh I know some some tournaments
prefer to rank higher those who who won
the most games
so for for this tonal mode for now we
are taking the the sum of the yellow in
case of wind
um but uh yeah again this is something
we are trying to test different for
example uh the last week we had like we
were like uh giving some points for a
draw like half the points uh but as you
know as you can imagine I see in the
chat so people can do collusion and
stuff like this so we have to we are
trying different way of uh of um of
giving points on the little boats and
and and mostly come from the community
and in accommodation community so for
now for this one it's the the win that
comes and and the wins versus uh uh the
hello the hello cons first hello we win
yeah I know that's always that's
something that you uh I don't think you
can uh I don't know if it's possible to
check the the additional criteria on
other websites either I know I once uh
once tried it I I couldn't find it uh
but yeah as you guys mentioned uh in the
beginning of the stream first stop uh
top three places will be rewarded uh a
price of an actual piece and everyone
who participated in the tournament uh
all
209 people will receive a token
yeah
yeah so the token that you will receive
is the utility token so it's the it's
the the token of the game and uh and so
the first one I will receive a polished
piece and uh the the the second and the
third one will receive rough pieces I
think it's a rook and a king so congrats
uh to all of you and these pieces now
are yours and you can play with them and
all the others will get some cmts which
is yeah the money uh of the game and uh
this money will soon be uh usable on the
platform to activate some perks uh so uh
you you should see it on top of your uh
on top of the website uh in your in your
accounts
yeah you can see that there actually is
it in the price pool there's a knight a
king a rook and also some uh some some
coins here that you don't have to do
anything to claim it it will just appear
in your in your account yeah
obviously as the as you mentioned
there's some can be some cheating
problems so uh the rewards are usually
distributed uh week week plus one so the
next week uh for this one we will make
sure to distribute it to tomorrow but we
do we do that to ensure we can we can
analyze the game because after after
each game is done we can analyze it and
with the Institute mechanism and so
usually we do that to to prevent uh
paying people right away and people that
have cheats so to ensure fairness in the
in the little broad payments so we take
one year one one week uh for for
payments is it so that sort of no okay
sorry
no that sort of tournaments will happen
uh very frequently uh from the coming
weeks and uh so they could be like uh
just uh regular tournaments uh Immortals
tournament with this game mode and those
tournament with GMS that will join the
tournament too so these will happen from
the coming weeks if you want to uh to
join them and you'll have also the
regular leaderboards that you can see on
your left which are the AP IP and
classical games uh and all of these
three uh our tournaments just uh weekly
tournaments so every Thursday uh it's
reset and then one week later uh the the
the rewarded distributed
okay and uh and it's always on the same
day
it's always on Thursday that the
tournament ends the weekly one but uh
the tournaments like the one we just did
will be uh held uh like on random dates
and pretty much every day in the near
future
okay if if you guys are wondering why
Meadow is twitching in the back he's
dreaming yeah he's not having a seizure
or anything
okay uh so a big congratulations to
everyone who joined and especially to
those who who were able to win uh uh I I
I did not expect as many players 209
players so that's very nice uh do you
guys have anything that you would wish
to add for for for the end of this sort
of an introduction uh stream into the
immortal game
no first of all thank you for adding us
it was fun it was it was not nice to see
comments there's some good some bites
um so we will keep you updated about the
the progress on the website about all
the Philippine responsiveness in next
coming months and uh hopefully if some
some are convinced they will come back
maybe a bit later in a few months and
few years at some points uh so yeah
we're really hoped and and we'll build
in that sense uh thanks a lot uh to to
others yeah no no yeah thank you so much
and uh and believe that that when he
offers today and uh and uh pray more in
the near future uh uh working out to
build uh a better product every day so
uh it's always challenging to uh show
your product early and that's the
decision we've taken so we will take in
consideration most of the con the all of
the comments and thank you so much for
being honest on what you've noticed and
what you're curious about up and uh
Antonio thanks for hosting it and and
make it uh uh yeah make it uh open to
your community and happy to come back
sometimes in the coming weeks when we'll
have a a the new version of the product
too yeah that's I mean that's one of the
reasons uh as there are there are there
are many uh people who are trying to
gamify chess and I I believe you're at
least the first one that I've seen that
actually has a sort of a working product
it's a work in progress but it's working
it it is a working product I mean okay
you can organize a tournament you can uh
distribute rewards so it is working and
I thought it would be nice for the
community to be able to ask you
questions directly about what the what
they're interested in
cool thank you so much for having yours
uh very early and uh it's a it's the
decision we've taken very early to to
show the product and to build it with
the community so that sort of uh of
presentation is also a way to uh to keep
uh pushing the word about it and uh and
be sure that we'll be there in the
future and uh the product will keep uh
evolving in the in the in the right
direction which is the direction uh
where you guys and chess lovers want we
want to go
all right maybe we can do an update and
update MMA in a few months to see how
how you guys are doing
sure definitely thanks again Antonio and
uh goodbye goodbye everybody until next
time
cheers bye cheers bye bye
all right guys that's uh that's it for
this one this was sort of an
introduction into into what this whole
Immortal game is as I was also very much
interested I I was not as familiar with
the project I had a conversation with
them uh about what they are doing and I
thought you guys might want to enjoy uh
asking them a few questions so that
that's basically what this was about uh
but yeah that's it for the stream thank
you all for joining uh be
congratulations to everyone who won some
prizes and uh see you see you soon in
the next video